depuis le début ils invoquent la
moralité l'éthique l'importance de
rembourser les contribuables n'aient joe
wright profondément croyant va même
jusqu'à citer la bible quand il veut
expliquer pourquoi il voulait garder le
secret sur l'argent qu'il a donné à mag
deux filles c'est comme dans le chapitre
6 de mathieu at il dit à la cour
vous devez faire ces choses discrètement
et la main gauche doit ignorer ce que
fait la main droite
mais l'avocat d'un mac de fil lui fera
surtout admettre que cela faisait la
sphère du gouvernement que les canadiens
croient que sénateur avait payé de sa
poche dans les bennes veut prouver que
ce sont des impératifs purement
politiques qui ont motivé l'entourage de
stephen harper a élaboré ce qu'il a
qualifié de scénario délibérément
trompeur qui avait pour seul but de
protéger le gouvernement
c'est pour cela que si nigel wright
pensait que mike duffy avait peut-être
légalement droit aux allocations
il a tout de même poussé à rembourser le
sénat il a pris la décision a dit l'ex
chef de cabinet de stephen harper
j'ai mis de la pression sur le sénateur
de filles et il était d'accord avec ça
il maintient que les deux hommes
s'étaient entendus mais quand vous
forcer quelqu'un à faire quelque chose a
rétorqué de robin
vous pensez que c'est une vraie entente
le premier ministre était très au
courant de ce qui se passe et sa clique
courriel démontre on a un premier
ministre qui continue de préférer de
dissimuler la vérité et si plusieurs
proches collaborateurs du premier
ministre
incluant son actuel chef de cabinet ont
été appliquées dans les échanges de
courriels stephen harper lui ne déroge
pas de son discours
je répète ce que j'ai dit depuis le
début je suis devenu conscient de la
situation où monsieur ta fille a fait
des des demandes pour des dépenses qui
n'étaient pas des dépenses des vraies
dépenses
si les explications de nigel wright
semblait si claire mercredi
le portrait qui émerge de son contre
interrogatoire et des centaines de
courriels déposé en preuve
risque fort de soulever de nouvelles
questions surtout en pleine campagne
électorale
et si daniel thibault radio canada
ottawa